there's a place in southern nevada where
loved ones veterans and military members
in need of medical care can stay for
free the fisher house located in the 215
in pecos helps keep families together
during hard times jeremy j ford has more
tonight
it's a beautiful place i recommend
anybody who's a veteran has a veteran
and family or a veteran to come here
construction on the fisher house was
completed back in 2016 and ever since
then the building has been welcoming
guests with a place to stay if a loved
one is receiving medical care across the
valley lynn hofscher is currently
staying at the fisher house with family
my brother brother-in-law is a veteran
and it's helping him tremendously fisher
house manager stephanie wheeler tells me
as long as your veteran is staying at
any hospital families have a cozy place
to stay let us take that burden that
financial burden from the families by
being able to house up to 16 families at
a time and providing free meals the
suites also include common areas a
kitchen dining and family rooms as well
as a patio they can stay as long as
their veteran or active duty service
members receiving care we've had people
stay here six weeks eight weeks so yeah
they can stay jeremy j ford live local
now